en los últimos vídeos hemos visto que si
tenemos n puntos cada uno de los cuales
tiene coordenadas x y déjame dibujar n
de estos puntos y tenemos el primero de
esos puntos de coordenadas x 1 es una
coma deja poner un 1 x 1,1 aquí estaría
el segundo punto de coordenadas x 2,2 y
seguimos agregando puntos hasta que
eventualmente llegamos al enésimo punto
de coordenadas x n coma tiene y vimos
que a través de estos puntos podemos
encontrar una recta que minimiza el
cuadrado de la distancia
esta es la recta
la voy a llamar de igual a mx de esta
recta es tal que minimice el cuadro de
las distancias a los puntos revisemos
qué son esos cuadrados de las distancias
también llamados el cuadro del error así
este es el error entre la recta y el
punto uno el cual llamó error 1 este es
el error entre la línea y el punto 2 le
llamo error 2 este es el error entre la
recta y el punto n ahora si queremos el
error total si queremos el cuadrado del
error total y ahí fue donde se inició
esta discusión el cuadrado del error
entre los puntos y la recta para
calcular esto prácticamente tomas el
valor de cada punto así por ejemplo para
este punto tomaríamos el valor de de uno
menos el valor de y sobre la recta y ese
valor de ye sobre la recta lo vamos a
obtener al sustituir el valor de x en
esta ecuación entonces sustituyendo ese
valor de x vamos
tener menos mx1 más ve este es el valor
que estimamos de y sobre esta recta este
s mx1 más no no quiero que se me siguen
muchas cosas en mi gráfica lo voy a
borrar así este es el error 1 este es el
error 1 y lo que queremos el cual los
errores entre cada punto y la recta
tenemos entonces aquí el cuadrado el
error 1 hacemos lo mismo para el segundo
punto y así fue como empezó nuestra
discusión sería de 2 - mx2 más b elevado
al cuadrado más puntos suspensivos para
indicar que hay un montón de puntos en
el ínter más tiene menos m x n más b
elevado al cuadrado y ahora que de hecho
sabemos cómo calcular esta m y esta vez
te mostré la fórmula más aún probamos la
fórmula podemos ahora encontrar esta
recta y podemos preguntarnos bueno
cuánto es el error que haya y lo podemos
calcular pues conocemos m&b así que
podemos calcularlo para cierto conjunto
d
y ahora lo que quiero hacer es llegar a
una estimación que haga más sentido
acerca de que también se ajusta esta
recta en relación al conjunto de datos y
para esto podemos plantearnos la
siguiente pregunta cuánto cuánto o más
bien qué porcentaje de
la variación qué porcentaje de la
variación en qué
está descrita está descrita por
la variación está descrita por la
variación en x pensemos en esto cuanto
de la variación en que hay variación en
llegue aquí hay un valor de y acá
tenemos otro valor de por acá otro valor
de y entonces hay mucha variación en que
eso es claro pero cuánto de esa
variación está descrita por equis o
descrita por la línea así que pensemos
en eso cuánto es la variación total de y
cuánto es la variación total de y
calculemos la entonces básicamente una
herramienta para medir la variación
total eni cuando pensamos acerca de
variación lo cual también es verdadero
cuando pensamos acerca de la varianza la
cual es la variación promedio en g y si
pensamos en el cuadro de la distancia a
partir de una medida central y la mejor
medida de tendencia central que tenemos
es la media aritmética podríamos decir
que la variación total eni es
simplemente la suma de las distancias de
cada una de las diez a su media entonces
va a ser la primera la primera está 10
hacerlo en otro color va a ser la
primera que es que uno
es que uno menos la media del ayer que
es tierra ya elevado al cuadrado más la
siguiente que es de 2 menos
el promedio de la ye se eleva al
cuadrado más así sucesivamente hasta que
llegamos a la última que es tiene menos
el promedio del hay es elevado al
cuadrado y esto nos va a dar la
variación total en que si tomamos los
valores de iu y encontramos su promedio
no sé quizás un valor que esté por aquí
pongámoslo por aquí aquí está el valor
promedio de james raya podemos inclusive
visualizarlo como hicimos para
visualizar el error con respecto a la
recta
supongamos entonces que esta es la recta
ubicada en el promedio de y la cual se
vería así y lo que estamos midiendo aquí
este error aquí es el cuadrado de la
distancia vertical entre este punto y la
recta para el segundo valor esta sería
la distancia desde el punto hasta la
línea para el enésimo punto sería la
distancia desde ahí hasta la red
y en el ínter tendríamos muchísimos
otros puntos
esta es la variación total en ese
sentido porque si dividimos esta
variación total en i / n vamos a obtener
lo que se asocia típicamente con la
varianza de ella que es el promedio de
las distancias al cuadrado lo que
obtuvimos aquí es el total de la
distancia al cuadrado ahora lo que
queremos ver es que tanto de la
variación total eni está descrita por la
variación en x quizá lo podemos ver de
esta manera nuestro denominador queremos
el porcentaje con respecto al total de
la variación en déjame escribirlo de la
siguiente manera debo llamar a esto el
cuadrado del error con respecto al
promedio esto va a ser el cuadrado del
error con respecto a voy a llamarlo con
respecto a la media con respecto a la
media de la cual va a ser la variación
total en que así nuestro nominador va a
ser la variación total en ye es decir el
cuadro del error con respecto a la media
de y el cuadro del error con respecto a
la media de y ahora lo que queremos
saber es qué porcentaje de esto está
descrito por la variación en x pero qué
es lo que no está descrito por la
variación en x queremos saber qué tanto
está descrito por la variación en x pero
qué tal si queremos cuánto no
cuanto del error es decir de la
variación total cuanto de la variación
total no está no está descrita
por por esta recta de aquí
x
recta por la recta de regresión bueno
eso ya lo hicimos tenemos el cuadro del
error de la recta lo cual nos da el
cuadrado de las distancias de cada punto
con respecto a la recta es la medida que
queremos nos da cuánto de la variación
total no está descrita por la recta de
regresión por tanto si queremos saber
qué porcentaje el total de la variación
no está descrita por la recta de
regresión esto estaría dado por el
cuadrado del error con respecto a la
recta porque esta es la variación total
no descrita por la recta regresión
dividida entre la variación total el
cuadro el error con respecto a la media
déjame plantearlo claramente esto de
aquí
esto de aquí establece
establece qué
qué porcentaje de la variación qué
porcentaje de la variación total no está
descrita
x
la variación
por la variación en x o por la variación
la recta de regresión así que para
contestar a la pregunta qué porcentaje
está descrita por la variación bueno lo
que quede aquí es lo que tiene que estar
descrito por la variación en x porque la
pregunta aquí es qué porcentaje de la
variación en i está descrita por la
variación en x y aquí tenemos el
porcentaje que no está descrito por la
variación en x así que si este número es
30% si 30% de la variación en lleno está
descrita por la recta entonces lo que
sobre será la variación descrita por la
recta básicamente los restamos de 1 así
es que si tomamos 1 - el cuadro el error
de nuestros puntos con respecto a la
recta sobre el cuadro del error de los
valores de y con respecto a la media de
y lo que tenemos aquí ahora es lo que
nos dice esto es qué porcentaje de la
variación total qué porcentaje la
variación total está descrita está
descrita
por la recta está descrita por la red de
regresión o por la variación por la
variación en x y este número de aquí se
llama coeficiente de determinación
coeficiente de determinación así es como
lo ha nombrado los estadísticos
coeficiente de determinación coeficiente
determinación también es conocido por
ere cuadrada este término lo has de
haber oído cuando la gente habla de
regresión pensemos ahora en esto si el
cuadro del error con respecto a la recta
es realmente pequeño si el cuadro el
error con respecto a la recta es pequeño
significa que estos errores estos
errores que tenemos aquí este error de
acá este error de acá son pequeños
significa que este errores son pequeños
y que esta recta la recta regresión es
en realidad un buen ajuste
deje de ponerlo acá abajo si el cuadrado
del error con respecto a la recta es
pequeño si el quad el error con respecto
a la recta es pequeño significa que la
recta es un buen ajuste para qué pasa
aquí si el cuadrado del error con
respecto a la recta es pequeño esta
fracción es pequeña y 1 - esta fracción
pequeña va a ser un número cercano a 1
así entonces tenemos que r cuadrada está
cerca de 1 lo cual quiere decir que la
mayor parte de la variación en que está
descrita por la variación en x y hace
sentido porque la línea es un buen
ajuste tomemos el caso contrario qué
pasa si el cuadro del error con respecto
a la recta es grande quiere decir que
nuestros puntos están muy separados con
respecto a la recta es muy grande este
error y entonces este número que tenemos
aquí va a ser un número muy cercano a 1
cuando le restamos un número muy cercano
a 1 a 1 vamos a obtener un número
cercano a 0 entonces si el cuadrado el
error con respecto a la recta
es
grandes y el cual el error con respecto
a la recta es grande tenemos que este
número es cercano a 11 menos un número
cercano a 1 nos va a dar un número
cercano a 0 es decir el coeficiente de
terminación es re cuadrada va a estar
cerca de 0 y en ese sentido esto nos
dice que muy poco en la variación en
lleva a estar descrita por la variación
en x o por la recta el fin lo que he
visto hasta ahorita ha sido un poco
abstracto en el siguiente vídeo
trabajaremos con muestras de datos
calcularemos la recta regresión también
calcularemos el valor de re cuadrada y
veremos qué tan bueno es el ajuste